very outdoorsy person they probably are
you keeping up because I know that
you're you're great at like hiking you
love to hike you love to be outdoors you
love to go camping that kind of stuff
yeah I do
are you keeping that up now were you
taking a little break I mean I I can't
really do much now I got another
fabulous symptom of you know things are
ripping in here as the baby grows right
so I can't really do it but I but it
have had a lot of experience you like to
get out there in the wilderness thank
you yeah we were you afraid of wildlife
I know people that are afraid to go out
in the wilderness because they're afraid
of encountering you know a bear or
whatever I I do
brave that kind of wilderness but I'm
very afraid of it
mainly because well you know like we my
husband and I we drove up to Canada this
year because we shoot the Handmaid's
Tale in Toronto and we did a lot of bear
country stuff and we learned a lot about
how to handle certain bears and how when
you run into a black bear and it comes
up to you you're supposed to fight it
off what really uh if it's a black bear
you're supposed to fight it you're
supposed to fight it and if it's a
grizzly you're supposed to lie down on
your on your stomach with your hands
like this and you're supposed to play
dead pretend you're dead but I just
don't know how anyone's instincts don't
go the other way
in that situation there's no situation
where I would fight any bear regardless
regardless of the color of the bear do
you any mean I wouldn't be like ah the
old black bear eh let's get it on see
like I wouldn't do that in a million
years no I don't even know how you have
time to identify what type of bear it is
no no
half the diamonds are confused but if
it's at grizzly wearing a dark coat I
don't know
but if you're colorblind yeah a good
question problematic
you